de france 24 ha hecho un recorrido desde
tempranas horas de la mañana del día de
hoy a lo largo de toda la ciudad capital
de caracas empezamos por el oeste
seguimos por el centro de caracas ahora
estamos actualmente en un centro del
este en lo tanto en el oeste como en el
centro de caracas pudimos ver votantes
no una cantidad excesiva o largas filas
como suele verse en las distintas
elecciones anteriores que han pasado los
últimos por lo menos 20 años digamos en
la era del gobierno socialista ahora
estamos en un centro del este de caracas
que podría decirse que son los
cuestiones donde la oposición que apoya
a juan guaidó y otras 37 organizaciones
suelen votar este centro que ven detrás
de mí abrió desde muy tempranas horas de
la mañana no tiene muchos votantes no ha
tenido muchos votantes a lo largo del
día y así ha estado toda la zona
alrededor de este centro como les dije
un bastión de la oposición también pudo
conocer una vez que entré al centro que
algunas mesas fueron apenas
recientemente instaladas porque los
miembros no se presentaron a participar
a hacer el digamos el voto entonces han
tenido que pedir ayuda a algunos
voluntarios para que se sientan y
algunas personas que si decidieran venir
a votar unos pocos pudieran ejercer se
ejerce su voto herminia ante este
escenario y con una oposición claramente
con escasa participación todo parecería
indicar que el resultado es predecible
no hay que favorecer al presidente de
nicolás maduro verdad
si en este recorrido que les hablaba que
hizo france24 en el oeste y centro de la
capital donde si habían votantes la
mayoría decía que iba a votar por el
partido socialista unido de venezuela y
sus aliados porque dicen que necesitan
la paz porque dice que la asamblea
nacional contestó en manos de la
oposición no hizo nada y en estas filas
no se podían ver participantes que iban
a votar por la oposición esto quiere
decir que los pocos votantes que han
salido a la calle pues sí van a votar
por el chavismo y pues si son los que se
van a dañar digamos de este nuevo
parlamento que va a ser instalado el
próximo 5 de enero del 2021
también quería recalcar que muchas
personas también de la oposición o unas
pocas que sí participaron en algunos de
estos centros con las que pudieron
hablar pudimos hablar decían que el voto
es la única manera de salir a votar pero
estaban en contra de que la oposición no
llamo a esta extensión decían que era la
única vía para poder ganar espacios y
que ya la perdieron